two rivers lad says in your main segment
you mentioned unmasking Flint what does
that mean I thought he was always a
public figure is this kind of like a
Voldemort thing this was one of them
today was a long day
it took a lot to get done because I was
trying you know doing this video talking
about the the Obama gate and the
unmasking of Flint is very very
difficult because most people don't know
what unmasking means so I'll give you a
quick breakdown for you know to answer a
question when the u.s. is spying on
foreign adversaries or foreign
individuals whatever it is foreign
people they're not allowed to publish
the names of Americans because Americans
have a Fourth Amendment right I'm here
Americans have a fourth moment right so
when the FISA courts the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance you know act
the courts say like we're gonna you know
spy on this kiss layout guy this Russian
then they get a document that says kiss
leox said this US person said this
unmasking is when they request the US
person's name be published for them not
necessarily to the public not to the
public so when Joe Biden made an
unmasking request what was basically
happening was he was seeking to find out
the private that the name of a private
American citizen that would help him
understand the context of this phone
call a lot of conservatives are upset
because the unmasking was seen as abuse
the conversation between the Russian
ambassador and Michael Flynn was not in
any way suspect an incoming National
Security Advisor reaching out to a
foreign diplomat and saying hey we're
gonna have conversations let's keep
everything chill is completely normal
and even the Washington Post who
published his name said this is what he
should have been doing so why then did
so many people in the Obama
administration seek to unmask the name
of this individual communicating legally
and correctly with the Russian
ambassador that's what people are asking
more importantly who leaked it to the
press and why did Obama have a meeting
about it on January 5th a day after the
FBI moved to close the case and then
struck intervened to reopen it a day
later Obama Biden Comey Sally Yates
Susan Rice a bunch of people have this
meeting where Obama gives them guidance
Susan Wright's rights as really we rice
rights is really really weird email like
we're just doing everything by the book
her cell to herself and then on the 4:00
on the 12th Flynn's name gets leaked to
the press from the Obama administration
and on the 24th the FBI writes out of
notes
oh you know why are we doing this do we
want to prosecute him or get him fired
why would the FBI be seeking to get
somebody fired unless it was true that
this the point of this was to sabotage
the Trump administration coming in so
here's what I tell people yeah a lot of
conversations about Obama gait and I say
straight up you want to be very very
very very careful about what you assert
right so a bunch of conservatives have
said straight up Obama was trying to
sabotage Trump that's that's hard to
prove definitively but what you can say
is the FBI was trying to get a Trump
administration official fired ask that
question that's your wedge in the door
the doors not open but get that wedge
there
I want that question answered why did
the FBI try say we have no interrogatory
information and Michael Flynn then Peter
struck intervenes as a no no no we'll
keep it open then in this meeting with
Obama day later they cite the Logan Act
a law that's never been used before
which is archaic to go after Flynn his
name then gets leaked the press here's
what here's my personal opinion the FBI
is gonna close close the investigation
Peter struck intervenes the in the
meeting with Obama they meant Comey
mentions the Logan Act they then start
basically going after Flynn on the Logan
Act in the Washington Post article that
finally published Flynn's name they do
also mention the Logan Act I think that
ceded the information to Flynn who
panicked and then in a informal meeting
ended up lying about what he had said
the FBI used that against him and they
said in their notes is it to get him
fired or prosecute him or you know what
are we doing here so it seems like it
was kind of a setup it seems like Flynn
may have made a mistake but it seems
like they were going after him he
panicked and then look perjury like
Obama claimed it was perjury if it was
perjury that would have been under oath
in a formal investigation Flynn this was
about it was not the case apparently it
was an informal meeting at the White
House and they're like ah we got you now
you lied why was he unmasked in the
first place the FBI said no derogatory
information what was their reasoning for
extending this and trying to use a law
that's never been used before stands to
reason mal-intent however all you really
need to say if anyone's asking is why
did the FBI want to try and get Flynn
fired
doesn't make sense that is not with the
lawn for law enforcement agent both be
doing after that there's some serious
questions that need to be asked if the
FBI was trying to get Flynn fired then
why did Joe Biden seek to unmask the
name of Michael Flynn I'm not gonna make
any accusations against Joe Biden I
don't know why he made on January 12th
the same day the name got leaked to the
press I don't know but I think it's it's
grounds for some questions maybe some
written testimony or something there
there was no grounds we now know for the
Russia Gate investigation if we if that
was the basis for a sound investigation
according to many of these resistance
and I Donald Trump types then it then we
also have substantially more grounds for
an investigation you know that in the
other direction I am not thrilled about
the incoming Lindsey Graham hearings
that's going to be happening to me that
sounds like it's gonna be boring I am
interested to know what they were doing
and why they were doing it and the only
I can really say is it would be in my
opinion improper of me to argue that
Donald Trump shouldn't have his own
special counsel to investigate why this
you know fictitious claim was levied
against him why for three years these
individuals who had no evidence who
admitted under oath it had no evidence
were lying about him I wonder if the
very least as a defamation charge that
could be levied but if I entertained
Russia gate for years and I did then it
would be unfair for me to say we should
not have an investigation to dig into
the origins of this there's a few really
important points one is that the dossier
they used as a large portion of their
pretext to start the Russia collusion
investigation into Trump which
ultimately turned up nothing was seated
with Russian disinformation even
socialist magazine Jacobin has said the
Democrats were pushing Russian
propaganda we really need to understand
why that happened so we've got the John
Durham investigation which is now
criminal probe they're gonna be
investigating a lot of things maybe
there'll be indictments I honestly don't
know the Horowitz report proved Feist
abuse this proved Evan unas was right
and now we're going to hear about we're
gonna have Lindsey Graham's with that I
see Lindsey Graham was it's Lindsey
Graham who's gonna be doing these panels
I don't know I don't trust that guy
we'll see we'll see how this plays out
but anyway long story short
you perhaps these resistance people
shouldn't have asked for these set set
these rules in play
this was the grounds for which they said
we should have a special council
investigate you know Special Counsel
investigation into the Trump
administration and now we have more
evidence to suggest that Barack Obama
was involved to what degree we don't
know some people are arguing that's a
bigger scandal than Watergate because
Obama knew about this when he shouldn't
have his own chief of staff sought
unmasking of a political rival it's very
very very complicated but at the very
least there is more evidence to suggest
wrongdoing here than there was in the
Russia investigation if we all
entertained Russia it would only be fair
to entertain something in the direction
I don't like the hearings I think
they're boring I think they're bad for
this country but if that's what we're
gonna get then so be it
the left Biden me too all that stuff
they argued for all these rules and they
got the rules they asked for they said
you know believe all women now that it's
affecting Joe Biden they're throwing it
off the window I'm not gonna play that
game if you put the Republicans and the
Conservatives through this whole thing
in the Trump supporters and the Trump
supporters say okay now it's only fair
that we get our investigation what's the
argument
yeah I'm sorry that's the case so this
turning something a lot longer based on
a question of unmasking but there I got
it all as a valid question
it was it was tough earlier today
because trying to do a segment that
walks everyone through was like it would
been three hours like I started and
stopped so often because I'm like man I
got explained how the FISA courts work
the FISA abuse 2012 2011 NASA NSA FBI
and you even said nobody knows what
unmasking is yep oh my gosh yeah well
chance to explain it though so maybe
that will be its own segment we'll see
how that plays out let's read questions
again oh yeah I was chatting with the
chat I was just hanging out yeah Lindsey
Graham I don't think we'll end up doing
anything so we'll see how things play
out Jamie says thanks for not being fake
news I always think you're as a you're
an objective as you're you're as
objective as possible here's some money
I really appreciate it nice I try to
just be like I don't like I don't care
if Trump wins or loses it really don't I
don't like the idea of bond I don't like
the idea of Hillary Clinton but in 2016
when it was like Trump versus Hillary I
don't care I really don't and so when it
comes to who's right and who's wrong I
think you might have said to me in 2015
sometime that you would prefer Trump
winning but only though the only reason
you said is because it would be great
for news I think you're like I'm just
will enjoy watching it happen the one
thing I said all the tonight it all on
fire no no the one thing I said all the
time in 2015 was if you like the status
quo yeah then you want to vote for
Hillary Clinton right the war the
intervention yeah and the American
economy like the way the Machine was
churning it was it was enriching a lot
of elites and I was like but if you want
you know it's it's it's it's a long she
likes to go on to people like if you
want to see either a complete disruption
of the system a challenge to the status
quo or you want to see America like it's
basically Hillary Clinton was the
interventionist candidate yeah you know
so it's like if you like everything
we're doing overseas the Middle East the
oil exploration the seizing of you know
the deposing foreign government of
governments and things like you know
we're moving foreign government and
stuff Hillary Clinton was your choice Oh
politics yeah but if you wanted
something different or you want to watch
the world burn mm-hmm people for Trump
yeah but Trump is you know I think my
husband back then was actually incorrect
because Trump really bolstered America
and like made it work really well yeah I
didn't expand see that coming thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you